this was a random act of violence
I have great sadness great sadness when
I walked in here today the first thing I
did was let's just have a moment silence
sudden Lisa Vanderpump heartbroken
following the deadly massacre at a gay
nightclub in Orlando Florida that left
at least 50 people dead and at least 53
more injured I think the most important
thing is courage in the face of
adversity ET spoke with the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills star who is
an advocate for gay rights during la
pride on Sunday what was your reaction
when you first heard the news this
morning this morning I think we were
really devastated and my heart you know
goes out to the victims and their
families and it's definitely thrown a
kind of very sombre shadow on today's
events which should be a day of
celebration I've had gay restaurants
bars clubs you know and I've always
known the gay community to be a kind of
peaceful community they embrace one
another and for me such a heinous act it
is devastating it was there any
hesitation on your part about showing up
today because you have such a great
responsibility to all your patrons and
people that work for you but now is the
time we stand together we we unite you
know if we if we don't know put and then
we
what are we showing with it they're
gonna win well is there a message you
want to send out to the victims and
their families you know we need to have
a moment of Prayer you know and really
understand that these people they were
just innocent victims and I'm I'm truly
truly sorry